Hi, my name is Sebastian Thrun.
>> My name is Katie Malone.
>> And this is the machine learning class here at Udacity for
everybody to learn machine learning.
I am a research professor at Stanford.
I am the founder of Udacity and
I also did things like Google Self Learning Car, The DARPA Self Driving Car,
Challenge Ways, Google Street View, Google Glass, Google X.
And the secret behind my work is, it all reduces to machine learning.
Machine learning is the core of what I do and machine learning enables me
to build amazing products and amazing user experiences.
>> I'm a physicist by training so I have a little bit of a different background.
But in physics we use machine learning all the time too.
And so what we do, is we start with gigantic data sets of lots of
particles that we create in our detector.
And we use machine learning to comb through those huge data sets and
to find the one event.
Or the ten events out of the millions and
billions that help us win Nobel prizes.
>> And doing good machine learning is just like making great wine.
So I have a bottle of wine here from Italy.
the, analogy goes as follows.
If you want to, going to make a really great wine you have to make great grapes.
And if your grapes are no good, your wine is no good.
Same is true for machine learning.
You need good data.
You need to really understand your data really well.
And then there's a technique to it to make really great wine and
it's really hard to learn.
Same is true for machine learning there's a technique to look at data,
to understand data, to be able to apply algorithms.
And if you don't master the technique you
will never be a great machine learning person.
>> So in this class, in our machine learning class we're going to start
with a bunch of machine learning algorithms.
But we're also going to be looking at some really interesting datasets.
And we're going to be asking some really interesting and kind of hard questions.
But questions that we think are going to be really cool to answer.
So we're going to start from raw data, and then we're going to
show a machine learning process that sort of goes from beginning to end.
So that you can start with a dataset of your own.
And you know how to tackle it using machine learning.
We are here in Silicon Valley.
And in Silicon Valley machine learning is a big deal.
Companies like Netflix, Amazon, Google and
many others use data on a daily basis to optimize the product experience.
And I can tell you, if you're proficient in big data and understand data
science really well, you will find a job in Silicon Valley, very likely.
And the starting salaries are unbelievably high.
They are often north of $150,000 to an $200,000.
>> And even if you're not looking for a job in data science right now.
There's still probably lots of ways that machine learning is something
that you use everyday.
So when I go on Netflix at night.
How do I figure what, what movie I'm going to watch,
Netflix makes recommendation using machine learning.
When I use my credit card, to make a purchase.
There's fraud protection on it, that's machine learning as well.
You're get some insights into how all kinds of tools that you use
everyday are working, and they're built on top of machine learning.
>> This is a really great class.
>> It's learning by doing.
We'll see you in class.
>> We'll see you in class